中华民族最古老的经典著作《易经》,是中国哲学思想的起源。无论是老子道可道非常道之中的道,还是孔子的五道意义观之中的一,都来源于《易经》中最基本的思想,那就是一阴一阳之味道。
那么阴阳是怎么产生的他们之间是什么关系阴阳的思想对中华民族又有了怎样重要的影响呢台湾师范大学曾士强教授将引领我们一起感悟易经的智慧敬请收看阴阳之道我们只有一个地球这句话现在大家都熟能详
因为听得太多了但是这句话到底是什么意思呢大家看过巴比伦的文化希腊的文化你说它不同嘛它又很相近你说它相同嘛它又差得很远那到底是近还是远到底是同还是不同你看西方它的所有的
文明都是从神话开始我想大家听了很多巴比伦有巴比伦的神话希腊希腊的神话那当然中文也是很多的神话可是神话能满足人类的需求吗你能够生活在神话当中吗我想不行神话听听你总是将信将疑
到底这是在干什么因此呢神话没有办法满足人类求知的欲望所以就产生一种叫做哲学每个民族都有不同的哲学而每个民族的哲学实际上都是从神话里面提升出来的神话只有一个目的
就是解答宇宙人生的問題哲學也只有一個目的就是解答宇宙人生的問題但是哲學大家總覺得好深好遠好像都在象牙塔裡面我們中國自古以來我們的哲學家從來沒有生活在象牙塔裡面你看孔子
它多半的貼近老百姓老子他多麼的深入我們的人心因為什麼因為我們是不分的我們是合在一起我們把理想跟現實合在一起我們把高的跟低的拉在一起所以神話它慢慢形成哲學哲學就變成什麼變成我們的智慧
那我们的智慧是什么就是一本《易经》嘛我们对《易经》的认识应该要很明确的了解到《易经》它不是告诉我们什么知识不知识的它不是如果《易经》是一本讲知识的书它老早就丢掉了因为那么久了什么都变了你就留了什么用
預經所給我們的是智慧預經告訴我們一切一切都是人想出來的都是人想出來的我們不用虛擬我們用想像通通是人想像出來的你說這是神話那我請問你哪個民族他的學問不是從神話來
那個時候哪有辦法一下想得很具體想得很現在所講的科學那不可能的想像都是從模模糊糊從不清不楚裡面然後慢慢去具體出現我們以前有手錶嗎沒有就是有一個那天想想想想那以後手錶就製造出來了
我们有钱有麦克风吗没有就是有人不断地想想想想到这麦克风就制造出来的所有的东西都是人想出来的我想这是《易经》给我们最高的一个答案《易经》告诉我们一切一切都是人想出来的事实上人类正是因为有了想象才有了大千世界林林总总的发明和创造
才出现了各种各样的意识形态和思想流派那么易经的思想又是谁想出来的呢就是复习想出来的那大家一定很羡慕啊那我也能够想出这些东西来那不是很好吗可以啊的确可以啊这一个方法而已减少你的欲望
你就可以往正當的方面去想我們把想到的東西叫做天機中文把它叫做天機肆意伸著天機前整天想股票明天想我怎麼樣去買環地償後天想我怎麼樣這樣這樣想半天的人他這個天機是完全沒有看到的
四翼潛著天機聲完全在自己傅希思想的是人類最重要而且是宇宙最高的一個秘密萬物從哪裡來傅希思看到太陽從東方起來然後一直走一直走從西方下去
他就知道了天底下有一種力量把太陽從東方拉起來然後一直把它往西方掉下去這個力量就使得萬物都受到它的影響好像它就是宇宙的根源那如果傅希思想到這裡
那我们就觉得这个人那真是要虚拟那真叫做虚拟因为不切实际吧怎么会断定他不切实际呢太简单了今天一个太阳出来明天一个太阳出来哪有那么多太阳一天一个一年就三百多个哪还得了就算有那么多太阳
東方有那麼大的太陽庫可以儲存嗎那邊也要一個很大的太陽庫才能夠一天釣一個一天釣一個所以傅希世他就自己否定自己我覺得這個對中國人也影響很大人常常要反省我們現在已經知道它不是事實
因為太陽它是永遠存在的只是地球自己在轉所以有時候看得到有時候看不到可是會不會影響到我們的思路不會林剛夫西是他最起碼告訴我們有看得見的部分就有看不見的部分有一個力量拉上來就有一個力量拉下去
他就產生了有兩種互動的力量的這種關聯一正一反一上一下這兩個東西就構成了什麼構成了太極裡面的兩個重要的一個內涵因此呢他就很想把他的思路把他表現出來
讓大家都知道可是那個時候是沒有文字的父親是他把這個力量用一個連續的線來代表我想這是很了不起的一種做法我沒有文字我說也說不清楚我乾脆畫一個圖像畫一個最簡單的今天叫做符號
那時候是連符號這個觀念都沒有的可見符號也是人想出來的他就畫了這麼一條線也許當初連畫的筆也沒有怎麼畫也畫不出來他就折一個樹枝就拿一段說這個就代表那個能量那個力量所以一畫開天的真實的意義就是一畫開天辟地我們講到這裡
已經很明確的知道當初啊傅希士他是用眼睛去觀察宇宙萬象然後他靠他的想像來替我們造出一套系統來這一套系統的總根源就是一話叫做太極我想一切一切都是從這樣開始的
傅希認為既然有一個能量有一個力量有一個方向就有一個相反的方向就構成了一種叫做什麼循環往復周而復始因此他就認為有一個陰就有一個陽有一個陽就有一個陰
福西上官天文下查地理思索很久终于一化开天地这一化就是太极宇宙中的一切都是从太极中生发出来的孔子在他做的十义也就是义传中写道义有太极是生两义就是人们常说的太极生两义
意思是太極中包含了一正一反兩種力量而這兩種力量就是陰陽那麼陰陽之間又有怎樣的關係呢?太極生兩儀兩儀就是陰陽如果傅希是想到這裡他就很滿意的那我們也是很倒楣的為什麼?
因為這就變成分的觀念已經出來了有陰有陽那是一個還兩個那明明是兩個啦那兩個就分了嘛所以佛西寺他就認為啊一還是一只是一有時候還是一有時候會變二就是一根木頭你不去動它它就一根木頭你把它切斷了它就變成兩小段
所以陰就是陽陽就是陰陰可以變陽陽可以變陰陰跟陽它不是可以分開的它是有高度的配合性後來慢慢他就想到啊我終於明白了陰中有陽陽中有陰他怎麼會明白呢因為他發現了把那個樹枝一折斷
就變鷹嘛那鷹把它接起來又變羊我想現在小孩子你如果給他一根竹子也好木頭也好他很可能不小心把它弄斷了弄斷就哭啊怎麼辦我們用膠水把它接起來這些事情對我們現在來講是很常見的現象可是在當時呢
呼吸式是發揮了它高度的想像力你會發現這個一化也叫太極也叫陽所以我們漢字在不同的場合它有不同的讀法它有不同的意義就從這裡來你說這一化算什麼這一化算太極可是到了這一邊只要音出現的時候它又代表陽
同样一花在不同的位置它不同的含义这个汉字里面是用了很多的大家有没有发现一二这个二跟后来那个可物可物的那个物是很接近的二就是有二心就是很可物这种观念都是从易经来的一你就觉得
很愉快為什麼因為大家合在一起同時呢他的力道很強我們今天說同心協力才有這種意的感覺二就開始分了所以他說如果陽是陽陰是陰對嗎那陽上來他可能往那個方向去他陰上來可能往那個方向走
兩個不配合兩個不協調彼此不調和這個宇宙會那麼有哲學嗎你看我們又得到一個觀念就是說宇宙看起來很亂事實上它是條條有理它是非常有規律非常有秩序的就是亂中有序
你看世界上所有的東西都是亂但是它都有戲亂中有戲這個也是值得我們好好去體會的老子說道法自然這句話是什麼意思道法自然不是說道去效法自然那不是這樣子因為道本來就是自然
所以道法自然這個法在這裡應該解釋等於道就等於自然可是當中文講等於的時候我們還有不等於的意思我想這一點是最神奇的我們中文慢慢要去了解自己因為它除了自然之外它還有一點別的東西在裡面我們用倫理兩個字來解釋它
《易经》那句话我们重复好几遍叫做自天幼稚既无不利就是你自己去了解天理然后你又顺从自然你就会得到吉祥你就不会有什么不利的后果
所以在这种情况之下我们所重在人在自己我没有悟到天理我有没有去悟到自然的道理其实易经就是把自然的规律把它转移到人四方面的伦理
所以伦理从哪里来从自然来自然那么有持续是谁在管呢如果傅希释当年说神在管那我们就产生宗教了他说没有这是阴阳的互动它是自然的应运并没有什么特殊的主宰没有
我們現在從物理學上大概可以了解到易經其實是比較接近真理的就是說它有兩種不同的力這樣子交付的去作用那很自然就產生萬物而且它會不斷的運行
已经认为阴阳是太极生发出来的,而且是阴中有阳,阳中有阴,阴极成阳,阳极成阴,彼此之间是互动合一,密不可分的,叫做一阴一阳之味道。那么这种阴阳的观念对于中国人的思维方式有着怎样的影响呢?
世界上所有的學問我們如果要用一句話來把它說清楚各位認為有這個可能嗎我相信很多人一定搖頭的哪有那麼簡單的其實真的一句話就可以概括包含所有的學問
那就是液晶裡面非常重要的觀念一陰一陽之為道今天生物科學家已經講得非常清楚世界怎麼能夠生生不息就是因為有物種多元化有不同的因素互相擊彈互相作用它才會生生不息
如果物種一元化搞到最後所有物種都沒有只剩下人類人類也會死亡的一句話講完了沒有矛盾就不會起變化不起變化就是死路一條這一陰一陽之味道非常清楚的在我們腦海裡面這個一陰一陽之味道
它并不是说一个阴一个阳那么合起来就叫道不是这个意思而是说自然的变化各位没有发现世界上万事万物不外乎四个字自然孕育但是它背后有一个道理那个道理它是永恒不变的
如果那道理一變那就每天出不同的花樣那社會還有次序那我們對自然還有信心嗎一陰一陽之味道告訴我們自然的變化就是陰陽之道陰陽這兩個字是誰加進去的是孔子加進去的
孔子說一有太極四生兩儀而這兩儀就是一個陰一個陽我現在講一個陰一個陽各位一定要清楚中文講一個就是兩個陽兩個就是一個它告訴我們這個一裡面是含有不同的東西在裡面那含有多少東西其實這個
我們很容易了解就是正仿上下高低輕重就是相對的兩種很多人一想到相對就說世界上沒有絕對的沒有這回事你看我們說世界上一切一切都是絕對的絕對沒有相對你有沒有聽出來這句話本身就非常絕對它根本就是絕對的哪有那麼絕對的
這就告訴我們一切都是有例外的這個在《易經》裡面是非常重要的觀念太極是我們的共性人再大也不過是個太極人再小還是一個太極人人都是太極甚至於漢字裡面每一個字都是太極叫做一字一太極可是
他會變化的他裡面有陰陽因為中國人同一個人有時候很講信用有時候非常不講信用有時候很守實有時候不守實有時候很振奮有時候很沮喪隨時都可以看得到人有情緒的變化同一個人他裡面有不同的情緒有時候他感覺到世界真是光明
充滿了希望有時候又覺得到處都是壞人怎麼我那麼倒楣呢同一個人同一個太極他分陰分陽壞人是不是一定壞人不一定壞人偶爾也會做好事好人是不是一定不會做壞事也不一定經常好人他做了很多壞事所以陰就是陽陽就是陰陰可以變陽陽可以變陰
我想這種觀念影響中國人實在是太大了因為西方人他比較認為陰就是陰陽就是陽這是兩碼事你問西方人陰陽是兩個東西還是一個東西我保證答案是說兩個東西很簡單陰就是陰陽就是陽可是中國人會告訴你它是一個東西
一个东西里面还有两种成分,一种叫做阴,一种叫做阳。合起来它就叫太极,太极分出去就叫阴阳。所以如果讲一,它就是太极,如果讲二,它就是阳跟阴。那这种观念,我相信我们是很容易接受的。
已经给我们的一内行二的思维和西方二构成一的认识使得东西方人的观念有了生和分的差异那么东西方的这两种不同的思维方式反映到现实生活中又有着怎样的区别呢一分为二这是事实一生二也是事实
但是這兩個字我們真的要好好去想一下一個叫做分一個叫做生分是什麼分就是分開西方人說一它會分裂成兩個是什麼原因因為一本來就是兩個東西構成的你看這四個字對他們文化的產生是非常重要的
叫做二構成一你看他們都是兩個合成一個所以很容易分成兩個你看西方的家庭它是由丈夫跟妻子構成的意見不合他就可以離開這他們的觀念我們不是我們認為一內行
这个二构成一是以二为中心一类行二是以一为中心一个家庭必须要夫跟妻才算家庭只要分开剩下一个都不算家庭西方分大以和他们当然也有和的观念不可能没有只是太重视分了分到最后它会变成什么
這很重要它會變成社會人群最小的單位就是個人中國沒有中國是合中有分我們怎麼分你都離不開要合合是最重要的為了合而分可以為了分而分我們認為保
所以你看我們的觀念跟西方人不一樣西方人認為社會人群最小的單位是個人我們呢我們認為社會人群最小的單位是家庭大家就慢慢知道說我們基本的觀念跟西方是有點不同這樣一來就產生很多後面的現象它是越來差的越遠
我們把這種現象叫做什麼叫做一本萬書就是本來只有一個地球本來只有一種現象但是你看出不同的東西來它就形成很多很多種變化一本萬書本只有一個但是現象是千明萬化都有
西方人看這個地球看到最後就看出一個結果他說啊我知道了就是一分為二一個細胞分裂成兩個細胞二分為四兩個細胞分裂成四個細胞那四分為八八分為十六十六分為三十二這樣無窮無盡的就產生萬物你不能說他不對啊
他本來就是這樣子可是偏偏中國人他的看法不太一樣他認為是一生二二生三三生萬物下面他就不講了因為不需要講萬物都產生了你等一下講什麼你看一二三再縮起來還是一二三再大還是一二三他通通是一二三
這樣各位才了解為什麼漢高祖統一天下以後他就簡簡單單約法三章這個是最切合中國民族性的一種做法有陰有陽誰都知道但是陰陽如果不互動的話什麼都沒有就一個陰一個陽有什麼用我們整個的思路
影响到我们民族的发展老子说一生二二生三三生万物用《易经》的思维来解释一是太极是一切变化的根源二是阴阳三是阴阳的互动如此一来自然可以生出万物来
《易经》广大精微无所不包那么世间万物又是如何从两仪进一步变化而来的呢我们现在一定要了解中国人很多思维是从《易经》来的《易经》告诉我们世界是一所构成的
可是這個一如果是單純的一那就是一到底了那這不會變化那怎麼會有萬物呢你管是有陰有陽如果兩個不互動的話那有什麼作用呢那不能發生作用所以他就知道陽一定會跟陰它會碰在一起陰會跟陽會化合在一起這樣才會產生萬物世界上東西它有陰有陽
而且分不開你看一天就好了你早上起來太陽已經出來了你會覺得熱嗎不會你知道上面是熱的但是那個太陽光的熱還沒有完全照到地底下來因此你就感覺到上面是熱的下面還是涼的所以叫做邵陽一定也要等到中午了
上面下面都热了就叫老阳到了黄昏的时候你们感觉到下面还是很热但是上面已经开始凉了因为夕阳它没有什么热的上面凉凉的下面热热的叫少阴到了晚上十二点哪里都冷
就叫老陰一天從早晨起來它就是從少陽到老陽從黃昏開始就是從少陰然後到半夜就是老陰一年來看春夏是陽秋
東是陰所以你不管在哪裡你都可以用太極生兩儀兩儀生四相來看所有的變化你只要把這個搞清楚然後採取動態平衡你就完全了解我們應該很尊重父系
因為祂那個起點很高很全而且讓我們永遠可以遵循這就叫做經所以為什麼把易經變成群經的第一個其實它是所有諸子百家共同的起源叫做群經之源
福西一化开天地这一化就是太极太极包含着阴阳两种力量也就是两仪而阴阳的互动又产生了四象那么接下来四象又是如何产生八卦的呢这八个卦又分别代表着什么意思呢我们下一集再讲
请继续关注八卦并乾坤